windmills are arguably the symbol of
Holland the village of kinderdijk is
home to 19 of them together comprising a
unesco world heritage site in the museum
area the Millers demonstrate the
technology cook fun and back loves
windmills so much he even moved into one
lives and works because the wind drives
the machinery well when the Sun comes
out you can see the shadows of the
windmill blades moving there's really
wonderful boy about four hundred
thousand people from all over the world
visit these windmills each year starting
in the 18th century the mills began
pumping water out of the land behind the
dike to make it arable today the mills
serve solely as decoration
deeper go home typical of Holland
windmills clogs cows and cheese that's
Holland the best-known Dutch cheese is
goda named for the city where farmers
have sold it for more than 300 years
others may also name their cheese Ghouta
but people here are proud of the
original it makes you happy it makes you
very happy yeah yeah just because of the
taste yeah and you know the way it is it
is made by the farmer's wife delicious
once a week in the summer the
marketplace in front of City Hall
becomes a stage tourists from around the
globe come to watch the old cheese trade
rituals when farmers and merchants close
a deal by slapping hands it is sold in
my country yes and that's one of the
reason that we want to come here I like
the whole the whole houses and the small
streets and also this market is really
nice
as well as being home to the famous
cheese Gowda has plenty of history
culture and of course a windmill
Holland's symbol also graces lots of
Delft blue the ceramics that did as much
as the painter yun Vermeer to put Delft
on the map found it in the same time as
for me I was making his beautiful
pictures here in in Delft and we have in
our factory also the familiar room and
we feel a little bit familiar with him
in the 17th century Delft pottery was as
precious as porcelain from China the
royal Delft Factory is still official
purveyor to the king and queen when
people think of Delft they think of
Delft blue automatically of course
together with premiere but they have
blue is one of not only the symbols of
death but also symbol of Holland and I
can Holland
Delft is also known for more than
ceramics because of the waterways the
city became a center of trade even Kings
settled here it's only a two-hour bike
ride to the coast one of the most
popular places there is not white where
locals as well as tourists from all over
the world spend their vacation
if God's elegance and it's got it's not
been ruined by sort of room architecture
Lisa's got the same sort of like beach
as it used to be 50 years ago like its
friendliness it's like a village I
traveled myself for a long time abroad
and then actually then when you when you
leave you realize how beautiful all the
next yes that's also because there's a
steady Pleasant wind here great for
water sports fans and for everyone who
likes a refreshing breeze